good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast even though you might
think it's the morning evening because
it literally looks like the world has
ended outside it's dark it looks like
evening time yeah it is such a gloomy
day here in New York but we're about to
bring the heat we're gonna bring the
sunshine with Tyler see let the Sun
Shine what song is that
Oh sunshine I think that's what it's
called by the sunshiners um I know it
just looks like I'm a regular girl you
know doing the morning toasts but you
may not realize that I'm a different
person please share with the class
yesterday I was just a girl doing the
toast okay today I'm a girl doing the
toast who also knows how to do the
renegade dance oh my god you have been
boasting about this all morning but I've
been too distracted to really you know
support you in your time of support I
spent literally the entire day like it's
mortifying the entire day learning the
renegade dance you should show us what
you learned Shane if I stand up is my
entire frame in the I think yeah I think
you're just short enough renegade
renegade nailed it great job sorry if
you're listening as a podcast today you
did not get to see the what the
brilliance that was my take on the
renegade beautiful stuff we're so proud
of you here at suppose I actually just
posted a talk right as we went live I
saw so you were in it and you are the
hardest-working tick stalkers in America
no because like there are people who
it's truly their job but I think that
we're putting on some premium content
like for me it's all about quality over
quantity which I know goes against the
tic-tock ethos his talk ethos I think
suggests and the algorithm kind of
creates an environment where you post as
much [ __ ] as you can it's just that's
just not my top priority and it's never
going to be I totally understand I just
wanted to let you know what the stalkers
are saying about you well today's gonna
be a great show because we have the Fast
Five stories but we also have Tyler see
we're also recapping The Bachelor much
to discuss
last night I was listening to this
matter before it went live sneak peek
and I think we're on the same side as a
snatcher finally I don't think that
we've ever gotten so many questions for
a guest as we did for Tyler say you know
as none of the questions are usable like
hey do you want to date someone who
lives on 14th Street and has brown hair
yeah can you open your DMS like sorry
I'm not asking him that like I want him
to think work well yeah we have we have
a tall task yes I think we're up to that
we're actually going to have to move our
camera up because we're so short and
he's so tall gonna look like else it's
gonna look like when TPG is on the toes
yes that which looks like elf when Will
Ferrell's in the classroom right Jules
so we do have a busy day should we get
right to it
yeah I think let's get right to it no
need to dilly dally because obviously I
was watching bachelor and the house was
in New Jersey couldn't watch because I
was editing this naturally I really do I
do love to dilly-dally
and there's nothing like it if I was on
a dating app I think that my hobbies
would include dilly dallying I think
that that's reasonable me too
um anyways without further ado without
further dilly-dallying here are the past
five stories that you yes you yeah yeah
you need you in the back seat of the
taxi it just keeps getting longer this I
know and then you have to embarrass oh
yeah but you yes you you in the back
seat of the taxi need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay whoa speaking of okay
today's episode is brought to you by
OkCupid have you ever been on a date
where you just had nothing in common
with the person a lot of people don't
know this but OkCupid has really changed
the dating game by asking you tons of
questions about yourself and what type
of person you're looking for if you
listen to our episode yesterday we
actually really dive deep into the
importance of being active on your
online dating profiles and OkCupid is
the perfect place to start because the
more questions you answer the better you
are they are at finding matches for you
with people you have something in common
with some of our favorite questions from
the OkCupid dating profile are are you a
morning person do you make New Year's
resolutions are you a chord cutter are
you willing to share your streaming
platform passwords with anyone they also
go a little deeper like asking about the
impeachment because honestly if you
don't agree with someone on politics
it's very hard to be married to them and
the most important thing about OkCupid
is that it works it is the most
mentioned dating app in the New York
Times wedding section which is literally
the only thing I needed to hear stop the
mindless time on dating apps and go to
the app where you choose what matters
okay if you believe yes you
OkCupid is free so we don't have to give
you a link or a code just download the
OkCupid app today go on a great date
this week and then tell us about that
great person my offer still stands if
you heard this message and you were so
influenced by my recommendation I will
come to your wedding
I will officiate your wedding and I will
sing at your wedding
only if you met your partner on OkCupid
sign on find love okay first story
little sad news Kirk Douglas Hollywood
icon best known for his role in
Spartacus has died at the age of 103 wow
I didn't realize he was in Spartacus I
was like I'm Spartacus right no yeah you
know it's always sad when someone dies
but I just feel like of all the ways to
die you know 103 beloved by the world
you know isn't a bad way to go yeah
leaving behind like a big family like
you did what you were meant to do i
wonderful legacy hmm um he's lived a
full life he was in his hundreds right
103
I just you know death is sad but I can't
be sad about this yeah I think it's this
is like beautiful a beautiful life and a
full circle and I'm sure his family's
grieving and I do feel for them but I
think that even they would say you know
wow it doesn't get better than that yeah
right yeah I would love to literally a
celebration of his life right like when
Heather Thomson had that weird party for
her dad who passed away at her house in
the Berkshires and they were all like
taking shots she's like it's a
celebration of life it was like her
first minute on Housewives that was
weird yeah that's interesting but I bet
I do get that like I've been to Shiva's
where everyone's just drinking and
laughing yeah like it really just
depends on like how the person died and
like whether it was a tragedy yeah no
one's taking shots at Lee no like a shiv
of like someone who suddenly passed yes
but like our grandfather you know who
who really lived and he really lived
like she can't be but you know I'm
praying for Catherine zeta-jones yeah
and Michael Douglas who you just found
out who he is I get confused between
Michael Douglas and Michael J Fox and
this whole time I thought Michael
Douglas was who I pictured Michael J Fox
house was in curb but I now realized
that they are two different people and
when I was reading Howard Stern's book
he did an interview with Michael J Fox
about his Parkinson's diagnosis
how like that interview with Michael J
Fox really really changed Howard Stern's
life like someone who was given such a
bad hand like could be so positive and
the whole time I imagine the other guy
like I I'm very confused it's I mean I
guess it is confusing
it's just as confusing as the Chris Pine
Evans of it all yeah
which a mystery that will never be
solved and you know what I don't want it
to dissolve still don't know who was in
knives out like the one from that is
Evans and that's also Captain America
okay Evans Captain America pine
Wonder Woman I didn't see Wonder Woman
but the last thing I saw Chris Pines in
was This Means War
yeah that was him but who was the others
Jason see them I thought no Jason see
them was bawlin no teachers have this
means of course yeah Tom Hardy he's a
relevant to this conversation I was
talking about the Chris's there's Chris
Pine Chris Evans and Chris Evans is the
one who was very weirdly linked
temporarily to ask a no Vale from
Vanderpump rules now you're going down a
road last jahnava I'll never forget when
I read that in a magazine as she was on
for once I know dating Chris Evans at
one point he was dating the wife from
the Polka king you know her she was
Jenny Jenny never called her the way
from the polka no because she's a really
accomplished comedian I just saw she has
a special on Amazon Slate fantasy and
she's also like the new Verizon t-mobile
commercial girl congratulations sir I
can't have this conversation for the
30th time you know what the more we have
it like it's all coming back yeah I
think we're getting better each time so
coming back so coming back to me now
okay next story Jameela Jamil comes out
as queer after backlash over role on
Boggan competition show okay weird story
this is a weird story it's taken a lot
of twists in terms but Jameela Jamil has
come out as queer in response to the
backlash after she was cast on HBO Max's
new ballroom voguing competition show
legendary she posted a lengthy note to
her Twitter with the title Twitter is
brutal and this is why I never
officially came out as queer I added a
rainbow to my name when I felt ready a
few years ago as it's not easy with the
South Asian community to be accepted and
I always
answered honestly if ever straight-up
asked about it on Twitter but I kept it
low because I was scared of the pain of
being accused of performative bandwagon
jumping over something that caused me a
lot of confusion fear and turmoil when I
was a kid mm-hmm
so the backlash um focused on her
supposed role as an emcee of this HBO
Mac show which she insisted she was not
she blamed deadline for that confusion
um because people were saying that it
should have gone to a member of the
LGBTQ community and then she posted her
note why did people feel that way is the
show a show is about ballroom voguing
which i guess is like a initiated in
thee yes okay I understand you know this
just kind of sucks because when you're I
sanju village meal I met her in so house
lobby and I was like so drugged you know
to take pictures and I took a picture
with her in lobby and she was so nice
and I just really like loved her I can't
stress that enough but it is really hard
when your job she's an actress but
really now she's like a full-time
activist and it can't be easy when that
activism like kind of turns on you you
know because she is such a outspoken
voice for minorities and just different
you know what's the term marginalized
groups so now it's like that
marginalized group is turning on her
which the irony is not lost upon me it
just sucks yeah she also said this which
I which I think is very important she
said I know that my being queer doesn't
qualify me as ballroom but I have
privilege and power and a large
following to bring to this show
sometimes it takes those with more power
to help a show get off the ground so we
can elevate marginalized stars that
deserve the limelight and give them a
chance well that's completely true
whether or not she's you know the right
subset of you know marginalized group to
be the host she's one of the most famous
women in the world right now and
regardless of whether anyone thinks that
she should be there or not she is gonna
be there and she's gonna bring a huge
audience of people who might not have
watched his show if she wasn't on it so
that I totally agree with and she's
right about that yes so there's a lot of
different um conversations happening
around this I think she still has the
job as of now as she should um yeah it
just sucks that like I'm sure now people
especially people in the queer lgbtq+
community which we are not so we're just
totally just like you know commenting on
this with no actual experience but I'm
sure like people are like doubting her
coming out
queer is like almost convenient when
it's like she said she has been all
along she that's never really shouted it
from the rooftops so for her it's like
this vulnerable moment of coming out as
queer when I've seen people on Twitter
just being like oh this is conveniently
queer so that must suck yeah and no and
it must and she said she's taking a
break from Twitter cuz I mean it's or
such a negative place I totally respect
that yeah but she does so much good you
know I know it's hard you can't really
get mad at Milledge amel she does have
genuine intentions yeah so we'll see how
this plays out and it's cool to see
someone who's gotten so much success
just off of like it's weird because
she's an actress but to me she's just an
activist like that's what she's famous
for and that's why she's getting invited
to the Oscars not because she was on an
NBC show you know what I mean so it's
cool to see someone who got so far just
like being themselves and doing good so
I don't think this should discount that
I really love Jameela Jamil yeah also
transparent star tres Lisette weighed in
on the issue also an interesting
perspective saying I interviewed for
this gig as the mother of a house for
nearly a decade which is what the shows
about
it's kind of mind-blowing when people
with no connection to our culture get
the gig this is not shades toward this
is not shade towards Jamila I love all
that she stands for if anything I
questioned the decision-makers totally I
think that's an excellent way of putting
it like knowing that someone tried out
for this job who literally lived the job
for ten years
that obviously is disappointing but at
the same time I don't know who that
person is and now we're talking about a
show it's like Jamila Jamila gives the
show a platform that it never would have
had before right so there's nothing to
be said for once again I'm standing
firmly in the middle because that's a
firmly on the side of Jamila Jamila
well I always stand on the side of
Jamila Jamila cuz she's literally my
head when she comes here the Kardashians
oh actually I agree even though they
should stop endorsing that flat tummy
tea like they're truly not there
Chloe has not they're literally like
millionaires billionaires they don't
need that money and she's right I'm
sorry but I don't like the way she
speaks them it's very negative yeah okay
well speaking of them
Kim and Kanye share sweet kiss at the
skins Nordstrom launch skims Nordstrom
has launched it is everything there was
a commotion person meet-and-greet oh my
god some toast here's my they got
premium photos models coming down the
escalator his schemes are gonna be in
Nordstrom's like they're really gonna be
available to buy as opposed to you know
waiting and waiting is heading alarms
but still I don't think we've spoken
about it in a while skins has become a
little bit more
well in terms of their inventory because
yesterday morning I bought the boob tape
and it had dropped the day before so it
was up for a full day and I don't think
it had sold out yet so before it was
like lunch at noon at 12:04 I was
totally gone
they're obviously ordering more
inventory enough that I could get
something 24 hours after a drop which
I'm so excited about and it shipped
immediately like I I'm like embarrassed
to show up big my boobs are but I need
to do like some sort of tutorial because
I never wear low-cut things because like
my boobs I need to wear like a full like
hospital bra medical grade bra I
understand even though a skimps has been
everything to me like I'm so skeptical
about this booty [ __ ] no way it can
do for me when I test for others right
and I saw the videos and it looks
amazing for girls with B but like no
we're working with somedays annex
yeah we're defying gravity like truly
hits you had died fine and gravity
kissing for Tyler um let's like feel
mouth you know I would you like this
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo and then I take like
hits shirt off but it like it I scooped
out his abs and I'd be like oh it would
be an HR nightmare yeah don't tell Theo
you know Thea's head of culture he's
head of HR yeah he wears many hats he
does does he have a favorite hat or
something no okay well anyways back to
Kim and Kanye they were being so cute at
this game's launch this is gonna be
major for her schemes for us she's
already on her way home but I love a Kim
in New York moment like she does it all
in a few days she runs shoot paparazzi
she vlogs she takes pictures of the fans
she eats lunch I just love it Kanye was
that you know Reza is still in New York
he went to lunch yesterday at Carbone
downtown and in the middle of the day
and Kanye was there and he took a
picture of Kanye was never where we need
to be we're never in the right place
always the wrong time always the wrong
time also I was so inspired by Kim and
Kanye's Architectural Digest photos and
videos that yesterday I completely Marie
Kondo to my house like got rid of so
much clothes that like even a short that
I wear the other day I'm like I know I
didn't even like wearing it like donate
I am seriously like I need to declutter
you don't understand I'm gonna be a
whole new woman I was moving furniture
like all because of Kim and Kanye you
know I have thought recently the few
times I've been to your house that you
didn't
de-clutter that's so hurtful no I'm
agreeing with it I think you need to
declutter I don't think so actually I
live a very minimalist life we had this
conversation the other day I truly just
need the shirt on my back that's how you
know low-key and humble I am no I I got
rid of so much stuff it felt so good I
could keep going you know I mean I was
moving end tables like I'm just I want
to get rid of all my furniture who needs
furniture
who needs things you guys also I
realized ever since we've been doing so
much toast merch it's all I wear and so
any sweatshirt that I own that isn't
toast I would never wear it again like
yeah it can go when I just recently
reorganized my closet I had so much
merch like and it's literally just ours
that my my bed that I got from Wayfarer
a few years ago actually is a big drawer
underneath it that I've never used so
that's now my merch storage unit oh
that's nice yeah because sweatshirts
take up so much space is in cabinets um
Zac and I got a love sack for a space in
our apartment and the way that it comes
it's like you have to break it down with
your hands it basically is a big block
of like almost a great material oh you
have to like with your hand oh my god my
hands were cramping that it was so funny
so crazy is it comfortable uh yeah it's
huge like it's gonna be such a cozy room
I'm so excited I'm really excited for it
I think it can be like a game changing
you should get some of those like tic
toc mood lights that like people put all
over their bedrooms so if it's like a
cozy vibe you turn the lights off but
it's still like mood lighting well I
have that big neon light so right now
love that my goal for this month it's an
ambitious goal and it might have to wait
till next month is to get my Home Tour
patreon up this month how long have you
lived in this apartment I don't want to
talk about it but how long for a year no
not a year how long did after stagecoach
oh so like eight months yeah okay your
apartment is done except for your second
bedroom yeah but like if I'm gonna do a
home tour like I wanted to be the best
of the best the crème de la crema some
people would say the French what does
that mean I think don't quote me on this
but I think it means creme creme of the
creme creme de la creme creme from the
creme if my French is correct it's the
creamiest of the creams right but creme
de la creme creme is the same word so
it's not cream across right you think it
would be crema that's actually an
interesting conversation craft sounds
like an American word but you think it
would mean cream of the crop but creme
de la creme has to mean creme de la
creme yeah so
think it doesn't mean like the creamiest
operated translates exactly to cream of
the cream but like the conversational
version means the creamiest of cream of
the cream like there's cream and then
there's cream got it
that's your French lesson of the day
it's nice to be um fluent in many
languages ya know being a citizen of the
world it's absolutely necessary to be
honest I'm just I'm always traveling to
different countries people are wanting
my autograph in different countries just
like come to class with me like lands in
France hello come to Bolivia coucher
avec la créme de la créme yeah I know
French okay um next story a little
podcasting business oh I love a little
podcasting business and it has to do
with some of the podcasting biz news we
shared earlier the song about the most
successful podcast earlier this week yes
yesterday yeah Spotify oh it was Tuesday
I apologize
so it was earlier this week it was a it
was you know what you really said it
perfectly says Spotify is buying Bill
Simmons is the ringer to boost its
podcast business you know I have heard
of this the ringer yes because it was I
think he was number four on our list on
our list
so I heard of him earlier this week
exactly it's the fourth podcast he'll
Spotify has done in a year Spotify is
making yet another big budget purchase
aimed at getting a lead and no you are
not getting pulled over a lead in the
growing podcast industry the streaming
music company has agreed to a deal to
purchase the ringer the podcast centric
media company run and owned by Bill
Simmons okay I'm happy for Bill Simmons
but this is just like exciting news for
TN n do they put figures in here what he
was acquired for I'm not seeing any
figures I do love a public figure well I
would like a public number but here are
some other public this [ __ ] siren has
been going on for two [ __ ] minutes
we're trying to run a business I am just
adding up things to do but shut the [ __ ]
up
oh my god it's so [ __ ] wrong I'm
literally just screaming sure that this
island doesn't get plays the podcasts
get away you need to [ __ ] go
already
you know what's the problem here it all
comes back see traffic patterns in New
York you know it all comes back on de
Blasio because look he's with me ten
minutes
president tried to get us I'd damn just
I hope they were 103 and die peacefully
with a long lineage behind them in their
sleep this is the fourth podcast company
acts you want to mute until and we
remain with us please right yeah we'll
meet him wait
if you were cut I don't even know what
the [ __ ] I was just about to say you
were watching the podcast only got
crazier yeah honestly I'm worried
something must be going on I know that
was a crazy siren I've always had this
idea there should be an app that lets
you know what the sirens New York
community are for like what calls
they're responding to so like is it
something that you need to know like you
know also sirens are a little dramatic I
think people especially in New York have
become desensitized to them like because
you're getting the same siren for like a
building burning down as you are from
like a cat caught in a tree yeah and I
just think there should be different
levels of sirens so that people really
know when to get the [ __ ] out of your
way and I feel like if we can hear the
siren up here like I'm just gonna say
like they're too loud they're meant to
be for the people in front and behind
you to get out the [ __ ] way right and
they can hear that at a lower decibel
yeah it's no reason that we're up on the
40th floor and we can hear yeah and also
like when people are walking in the
streets and like a siren passes like
it's deafening no it's in like for dogs
and babies it's like actually
traumatizing and for us and I don't know
if I'm hearing phantom sirens now
because we were like listening to a
siren for so long but like I'm hearing
it yeah it's I think we should like like
start a movement that we could just
lower the volume on sirens just slightly
it's really they're meant to affect the
person right in front of them and they
can hear perfectly right obviously me up
here doesn't really need to know that
there's an emergency downstairs because
I'm an unaffected yeah look if I'm close
it should be that if you're affected
like you'll get something on your you
should get it and alert in this app I'm
developing ducting that lets you know
what the sirens are for you know is it
someone like so they say you know what
degree what level is there a fire of
hurricanes or level one through five
like emergency should have the same yeah
I just think that's something to think
about
okay um back to this podcasting news
this is the fourth podcast company's
acquisition Spotify has made in last
twelve months last year it spent about
four hundred million dollars to buy
Gimlin media anchor FM and part cast so
I think that gives you a sense of what
they're spending on they're spending a
little over 100 mil per I could really
use a hundred mil it's interesting I
think that most people with iPhones
listen to podcasts on iTunes and Spotify
is now just trying to like buy their way
into the game which i think is really
smart there's no reason why actually
they shouldn't be the leader in
like I don't use iTunes or Apple music
but I listen to podcast app but I I'm
always in Spotify like I think that
they're gonna do a really good job of
keeping people and Spotify to listen to
podcasts right like all my audio needs
right now are in Spotify and a lot of
the toasters tell me that they actually
like listening to podcasts on Spotify
more because they don't download
automatically and take up storage on
your phone like a lot of toasters like
streaming
yeah they delete the podcast app and
then redownload it because it takes up
so much data with all the episodes if
you subscribe it'll automatically
download it for you which takes up a lot
of storage and Spotify doesn't do that
but you can't download something offline
if you want to listen to it on plane or
something but it doesn't automatically
do it and take up storage which i think
is super interesting interesting well
yes Spotify CEO told recode that with
the wringer were basically getting the
new ESPN what Simmons has accomplished
in just a few short years it's nothing
short of extraordinary I'm feeling so
inspired I don't know about you but
designed on that all of his podcasts are
now only gonna be on Spotify uh that
could be part of it uh later on unclear
it's not just his own podcast but his
whole network that's doing really well
he's a talent magnet
oh wait wonder what other oh he launched
a TNN that's what I'm saying interest
that's what I had something this could
mean something for us being acquired
this is what I was saying
oh and understating news for TNA well
now that the story directly affects me
I'm even more intrigued right so I think
like he was working on this for a few
years 10 and it's just a few months old
we've got to put in some some years of
becoming quote talent magnet and then
maybe Spotify CEO Daniel Eck will be hi
Daniel is your daughter a toaster I
definitely think I'm a talent magnet son
I'm not a talent magnet yet definitely a
food magnet but I'm working on the
talent thing okay I would love to be
described by like a CEO as a talent
magnet yeah Wow
what a compliment totally okay for the
final story a little New York is news
sort of actually New York City renders
no longer have to pay broker fees so
this is like a huge celebration if you
don't live in New York you really don't
understand how big of a deal this is but
like how many times specific to New York
thing broker fees I don't know good
question I mean ask me how many times
I've literally fell in love with an
apartment and then found out that it has
a 15% broker's fee and had to literally
leave the apartment because I wasn't
forking over like seven
Rand yeah because brokers fees were
going up to us usually around 11% but as
much as 15% of your and I will read so
the burgers fee would cost sometimes
more than a month's rent a month's rent
wild I mean I'm really happy as like a
tenant um but how do the burgers feel
about this no but so now I think the new
law is requiring that the owner of the
building pay the broker's fee whether
it's like an owner a condo owned by like
a person or like a rental owned by a
building yeah the fee is not going away
from the brokers pockets but the renters
no longer have to pay it it's like we're
shelling out red now security deposit we
have to move in feed move in deposit buy
all of our furniture and you also want a
[ __ ] broker's fee yeah but I can't
imagine how many apartments have like
lost potential tenants because no one
wants to pay a broker's fee it's so
expensive and now the New York Post says
landlord groups said the change will
force them to raise rents on their
apartment oh my god we can't win you
guys I'm moving to LA here ha la la ting
is six-month sabbatical I hope you'll
join me or else I'm out of work I'm
gonna move to LA for six months and see
what happens you know what I think might
happen like even though I'm gonna be so
Beverly Hills like Fashion Issue
I feel like I'm gonna realize I feel
like in New York we always say there's
like really no one here but it makes us
so fabulous and like so desirable but in
LA like everyone fish big pond yeah I
mean you're the biggest pond in the
world no but in terms of like what we do
yeah industry wise we're like the
biggest things in New York because
nobody lives here so don't really do
anything even though there were the
biggest things we don't do anything
outside of what we did oh yeah operated
operation I think that if we left we
would realize I think we feel like
nothing goes on in New York but when you
go to LA you realize literally nothing
goes on everything closes at 1:00 like
New York every time I go to LA like put
its put into perspective for me how much
there is to do in New York when it's at
times it can feel like there's really
nothing to do they get dressed up for
everything like every dinner like it's
to the nines and in the city it's just
not like that no but like city in LA
like the dinner you're dressed to the
nines because it's the end-all be-all of
your night like the dinner is the event
that sounds like my kind of event you
know I don't know I just think like the
toasters were really into the idea of us
calling LA and like getting premium guys
first six months yeah so it's no I mean
by the way I would totally do it
who would love la would love it so would
Ben he could open up a pop-up medical
practice like he would be all the rage
yeah I don't know I'm just um Ben with
I'm like I never see me so Ben's job is
half based in LA so he actually could
move but logistically like what do you
do with your apartment when if you were
to just leave I don't want to lose my
apartment I love my work I mean you
either have to just like pay the rent oh
okay what if we're in LA and we're
influencers like you could go into one
of those buildings that like pay you to
live oh my god I would rather die and
then or I don't know if your building
allows you in New York doesn't allow you
because New York doesn't let you do
anything that's worthwhile you could
rent it out like a sublet right but
that's like it's so illegal it's so
illegal
whatever can we talk about The Bachelor
sure it was the second episode of the
week two hours plus the first our first
episode being three hours it was really
doesn't yet another example of the
network taking advantage of Matt Tom
malwan mass beer at Matt trust really it
was um but it was all worth it in the
end to see me kinda go home
also I got a migraine watching The
Bachelor and you know what the last
migraine I got was on Monday night
watching The Bachelor and I took my new
migraine pills and they didn't even work
oh that's terrible yeah it was really
rough when I woke up with a migraine
again I was like I can't have a migraine
for Tyler see so I took another one but
like I have to get my prescription
refilled already like you have to stop
grinding your teeth that's what you do I
know oh my god I need to get my night
vision night guard the Nights Watch I
know the garden I cart CCS or just look
like Invisalign but I want one that goes
around my head of course like headgear
yeah okay so the episode was actually
really boring um nothing that crazy
happened Hanna Ann had a one on one
where it was just so strange like the
whole episode was so disappointing
because it again just cemented how
really terrible of a bachelor Peter is
and absolutely no slight to him he's not
a bad guy he's just a bad bachelor he
makes absolutely no decisions when he
called that two-on-one for Tammy and
McKenna and was genuinely trying to get
down to the bottom of the drama why does
he care he doesn't have a connection
with either of the girls I know and like
he has really strong connections with a
lot of the girls in fact I think he's
gonna like become a polygamist and marry
all of them I was I I think he's in love
with every single one of them so I don't
understand why he even gave two shits
also like you know I'm not here for
Tammy or my
Hannah but in the looser and looser
crime that was happening I actually was
on Tammy sigh oh my god of course I was
she was being hilarious
I mean hey Makenna city or nothing and
Tammy said here I think everybody's just
like of a--sort I think no I was
literally like Tammy I think you are
everything like she was so convincing
that you know what I only realized in
last night's episode that McKenna is 22
which makes sense everything is now
making I see Hannah Ann 23 but Hannah
Ann is a slightly more mature um we kind
of just like literally any time she
spoke to Tammy getting like a frog in
her throat like she just she was not
built for this life like she couldn't
handle the confrontation she was like I
am powerful and you are weak and I am
strong and I read this in a book like
late season anyways I've been saying
this from night one where like she
thinks she's everything on the short and
she's gonna become famous and she's
gonna be going viral on Twitter with all
of her different facial expressions and
like her female empowerment quotes and
it's like you're not empowering anyone
like her whole speech last night well
I'm trying to like be I don't know the
voice for women that nobody asked for
nobody needs Jaggi she's literally the
Gloria Steinem that nobody asked you or
wanted like it's so it's so transparent
you will not make me feel weak I am
powerful but do you see like you all
seen right through this right course
it's just like wanting to become a Jif
that you send around to your friends
oh she's so vapid and every by the way
she has quote-unquote cried this entire
season 15 times and I want to make a
statement to say I have not seen one
tear I've seen a lot of and a lot of
like sniffles but not a single tear shed
and I think that's important to know
because she's such an actress she's so
fake I can't stand her everything I
thought that I would feel more gratified
when she left but I did it because she
was still being insane no I am powerful
he's still got way too much time on the
show in order to further her career know
she's everything that Tammy was saying
Abishag hashtags and she's here for the
frantic that's exactly what the problem
is with her Tammy is right but Tammy
lost her credibility by being a nutjob
last week Oh first sure but you know
even a broken clock is Right twice a day
yeah and the thing that was so
frustrating about the entire situation
was not only was it the definition of
looser and looser crime at the end of
the day Peter has absolutely no
connection with either of these women so
why he would spend
his time before rose ceremony really
genuinely trying to get down to the
bottom of it when at the end of the day
it's totally irrelevant they were both
going home regardless because now it's
only the people are better left there he
actually likes and they had literally no
connection with him so he was spending
his time that's what Kelly was saying on
her tainting on Monday which I totally
got she's like you're just giving into
the drama so much and it shocked me
because I'm just not at that part of a
point in my life anymore and she was so
right like literally Peter this episode
was acting exactly what Kelly said he
was acting like a child
yeah okay so with the eliminations this
week a lot of people went home our top
four has been rocked who was in our top
four
Toria P oh and I think Sydney was at
least for me I don't think Sydney wasn't
leave he sent send me home like I
thought he was so in love with her yeah
I know but when you think of the girls
who are there to me she was the lowest
in terms of connection she was very
special when there were 12 girls left
but now that there are six no but like
okay Kelly like his top just wants to
keep her around to think that he's good
enough for her but he is nothing on this
yeah Madison the cuteness her always the
girl who gets the first date lasts till
hometowns um Hanna Anne it's just like
she's great he's okay but they're not a
match no I didn't even think she was so
great I thought their date was
incredibly weird it's like an order I
think in order had a better connection
with him than Hanna an order for Peter
to think that you are there for the
right reasons you need to get up and cry
yes I don't want you to be perfect like
you Victoria F she yes officially I'm
done with her
what is going on second day in a row
where she's gotten up and cried
conversations of I can't I don't know
like what are we talking yeah it's
not--and link so it's hard the Hannah
date and the Victoria date we're both
the same thing
talking with no substance I just I can't
do this what can you do elaborate please
I need elaboration no you're so right
it's literally just no context no
substance no meaning just literally
being like literally like I'm just so
confused what what explain it what are
you confused about it's so hard and then
like fast forward to 1 minute later
Peter thank you for sharing you know
like that's what I needed from you can
you elaborate what what happened that
needed what can't you deal with Victoria
looked sickening on her date I loved her
at a flatiron yeah no she really is very
beautiful yeah but she oh and I saw
TechTalk that was doing like look-alikes
of people from The Bachelor
and they said the Victoria fuller looks
like Daniela Bertolli and it's so true
oh I saw that she looks like Nemo from
Finding Nemo I don't know how someone
could look like a fish but uh the chick
talk was really convincing like if you
see a pictures of junior goalie and they
look really like she was on Brant
because I was starting last night
looking like Darla do you know her
oh of course a fish tank a she with a
headgear that's you so a lot of girls
ended up going home because Victoria
sent herself home and then we lost
herself home oh right sorry he was
[ __ ] booted and that's another one
who it's like I thought he was equally
in love with her and he was nothing of
the sort
what's confusing and what we've been
saying from the beginning is that Peter
looks like he's absolutely in love with
everyone like even McKenna like he
really gives everyone the same amount of
like attention and love that you really
don't know if you actually like summer
doesn't the only one who I see a little
bit of a different chemistry with is
Madison like he'd grown her that script
he brought her like he was bringing her
stuff yeah I do think the top two will
be Madison and Hannah Ann and I do
really feel like Kelly's really gearing
up to be a nice Bachelorette I would
love I would love that like someone who
could talk I don't think I don't think
Hannah Ann's gonna be top two because
they really actually don't have a
connection I think it's gonna be Madison
but I don't think he would end up with
Madison also like I don't know that he
ends up with any of them I just need to
talk about one thing to the snatchler
already and you guys should listen it's
already up wherever you got podcasts
they made a really good call that
they're like all of a sudden rushing
through this season like six girls a
week after next is gonna be hometowns
um and so she thinks this natcher thinks
that they're getting all this stuff
moved really quickly because they're
still filming more things that are like
happening in real time you know like
maybe like a Peter Henry
oh I mean they're perfect for each other
I mean yet cuz they both are terrible
decision makers if we literally if we
endured these terrible girls and a
terrible season of Peter just so he
could get back with Hannah when she was
there on the first second and third
episodes I will be really annoyed and
this is this is why I stopped watching
The Bachelor like seasons like this
I just taking advantage of my
intelligence of my time like I just I'm
really done I I couldn't even get
through the last night's episode it was
so painful
here's the thing I actually think he has
really good girls
the problem is I don't mean they're so
mean and the problem is they've all
spent so much time watching The Bachelor
and realizing how you go far below how
you become the runner-up how you become
the bachelor to open up to Peter tonight
no but I have nothing to open up I'm
scared that's like the textbook formula
of how the bachelor goes and that's what
the producers want you to do but I think
a lot in the past a lot of successful
girls on The Bachelor have found you
know public love and adoration from like
these resistances to to the lead you
know saying like I need more I can't do
this
like even Andi Dorfman and Juan Pablo he
was the first person to kind of like
walk out and gave him an end right and
give him [ __ ] and like getting far
enough but not winning right that's what
Victoria F is trying to hand off right
so I think all around girls want to be
that girl who they don't want to win but
they want to be the people's champion
but they need to make it far enough in
order to be there right and so now we're
at the point where it's like okay am i
famous enough do people at home like me
enough how many episodes is this to meet
for me to turn on The Bachelor so they
all are doing like this thing where they
are kind of like dumping Peter at and
even though it's nice when one person
does it that's not the bachelor it's not
a show to watch this guy go from having
25 girls do you want to be with him to
having nobody honestly I think at the
end of the day he should choose Kelsey
because she actually loves him I totally
agree I absolutely adore Kelsey she's
literally so beautiful and I like I know
what everyone thinks she's crazy but I
kind of like how like every time she
talks to Peter she like gets a little
frog in her throat and cries because
like it's just so real like that when
you love someone I'm like you're having
such a hard time and like he's dating
other women like that's a very normal
reaction and I know that everybody
thinks she's crazy but like I love her
and I really feel for her I think that
people are warming to her and I think it
could be her in Madison as final - by
the way you just really you said it
right there that like the only one who
genuinely like loves him is Kelsey yeah
and I think that's why I don't know if
he loves like sir just as much but
that's definitely why he's keeping her
around it's nice to have someone around
who likes it and it's like they're
teetering on okay he can't like him too
much or else you're sent home like
Victoria Peak right even though there
was something totally batshit crazy
about her we'll never know what it was
she was not to be trusted and can
someone explain the glasses and the
evening gowns because we know she has
contacts cuz she's not always wearing
glasses I was thinking maybe she got
like an infection or something that she
had to wear her glasses because that was
weird I think she
going for like a sexy teacher look and
the first one or two times I thought it
was like she was I thought it was cool
because no one wears class and then she
really stood out but then she's wearing
like this slinky sequined dress and
glasses it made no sense Amy no sense
yeah I thought that was we were too but
I was just so excited that she was going
home we're really cleaning house
Victoria F needs to go next she needs to
go and then I think weird she can't and
it's hard and she can't deal yeah
natasha is still there when honestly
she's never spent really a lot of time
with Peter I just think that Peter likes
her as a friend and I also think Peter
like Natasha is such a great girl and
it's just like Kelly he wants to think
of it himself as the Krait man that
could have a woman like that when he's
nothing of the sort
that's so true but you're really nailing
these thank you I mean it's not so hard
to analyze these people but it is
becoming increasingly hard to watch this
[ __ ] but very someone asked me actually
when we stopped watching for a Hanabi
season how come we started watching
again but because apparently Hanabi
season was amazing with the one we
decided to skip yeah and I just needed a
break and then I felt good about
watching again um and I don't know what
the problem is with this season I it's
Peter it's Peter and he's just like he's
hung up on the wrong girls and I don't
understand I'm gonna ask Tyler see if
he's been watching and like what do you
thinks about his friend doing a terrible
job yeah I just to me gets the same
connection with like Sydney as he has
with Victoria like really into them no
to me he literally loves everyone and
would marry them in 10 seconds it's true
I just don't understand how soon he went
home I thought she was gonna be final
two and I'm just loving ABC being so
transparent like really leaning into
Peter's 25% Cuban background so they
don't get [ __ ] on for not picking
someone more diverse yeah also I just
want to say I love the telenovela date
say [ __ ] hilarious Kelly as the
grandma McKenna has made when she was
falling over and trying to be like maybe
you'll end up with abuela so funny so
funny so couldn't you really got to see
people's personalities I think we should
bring out Tyler I'm very excited to see
him he's looking snatched and you can
too with daily harvest we're all
overbooked overstimulated and constantly
running on empty
for us we're always rushing to produce
episodes and patreon and there's just so
much to do we barely have enough time to
eat complete meals let alone prepare
healthy ones very true being busy
doesn't mean you have to resort to take
out our overly processed food that's why
we love to airily heart rusty deliver
the food you want to eat but don't have
time to make it right to your door
we um now that we have our office and a
kitchen we've been able to keep daily
harvest in the freezer and it's actually
really great for work workday you know
snack him yeah they made smacking they
make it easy to eat more fruits and
vegetables with thoughtfully sourced
chef's crafted foods that can be
prepared in five minutes or less they
work directly with farms to harvest
organic fruits and vegetables at their
peak and then freeze them within 24
hours to log in their nutrients
everything stays fresh until you're
ready to choose to enjoy it choose from
more than sixty five different options
like smoothies hearty soups harvest
bowls and overnight oats whether you're
at home at your desk or on the go
daily harvest is the best way to enjoy
delicious and nutritious meals or snacks
go to daily harvest comm and enter the
promo code toast to get $25 off your
first box that's promo code toast for
$25 off your first box at daily harvest
com daily harvest com code toast
sign on get healthy we will be right
back with Tyler see stick around if you
have questions for him drop them in our
YouTube stream and see in a minute
we are back in studio live in living
color with a man who we've been trying
to get on the show for a year but I
guess now he is the time for us it is
Tyler J Cameron everyone welcome good
morning to the J stand for Joseph Joseph
nice my dad's brother so you're living
in New York now
well yes full time full time what do you
think I Love New York so I just spent
like two months in LA mm-hmm and I was
like I was great as finally one
mountain-climbing got to go out you know
all of LA and then I came back here I'm
like I love the city there's so much
energy so much going on you Jonathas get
in a car everywhere you need to go you
can take a subway and beat any way you
want 15 minutes I love New York City do
you like to walk I love to walk like
yesterday I had a meeting on like 50th
Street and I'm like way down by the
Manhattan Bridge I walked all the way
out there just because like I enjoyed I
was like I don't have office I just
enjoy being around it I'm sure it also
takes you a shorter time to walk because
you have like I guess the length of life
is a little short stumpy let's get a
long torso I'm 6 foot 3 and my torso is
probably 5 foot 8 of it Wow must be nice
must be nice but we're so excited to
have you we've just been recapping the
bachelor peter season are you watching
I've not really watched or been up to
date on any of it really so you have to
fill me in a lot of it well Philly man
here's your friend
yeah yo he's your friend yeah he's not
doing a great job I'm sure it's a really
hard position to be in but it's even
harder when you're so indecisive yeah
and you just like listen to the first
thing people say and you make all the
girls feel special so we don't even know
who he actually likes yeah I think it's
a very difficult job better him than me
yeah but I think it's very hard because
you have a limited amount of time you
didn't know these people so you try and
you know get the you know get the best
of them and take it you know take what
you get from them and then you know
sometimes I guess you have to do rely on
other people's you know what they're
saying about that person you know cuz
like first when I was on the show Hannah
didn't see all the stuff that was going
on behind you know closed doors I think
Peter was aware of that and now I think
that's why he so sensitive
I'm really sensitive to it and try to
get understanding of cuz Hannah didn't
want to hear from us right you know she
was right about that
I understand which I which are you
gettin so he probably sees that he's
probably trying to the opposite of that
and trying to really understand what's
going on so there's not same kind of
thing that happened to him or were you
offered the job of a bachelor at the
time or no because you were in a
relationship no we talked about it but
it just wasn't where my heart was that
and I'm you know in Peters agree for the
job yes yes everyone who's the lead like
gets a lot of flack yeah you're damned
if you do you're damned if you do
exactly you can never walk away from it
clean like you know it's tough I mean
you're going you're dating thirty girls
and you got to figure out who's best for
you and the time is very limited you
know and so I think you know he's giving
his all that's all you can ask for do
you know any of the girls from his
season um well I didn't listen to the
toast so if you want to go on a date
with them you can ask them out have any
of them caught your eye
um I don't I haven't watched enough to
know you know there's a very there's a
lot of very pretty beautiful girls but I
haven't watched enough to like would you
date someone from the franchise are you
single right now are you saying oh yes
you're single is it frustrating because
you know you go everywhere and you're
standing next to someone and suddenly
you're dating Juliet Porter I just saw
this yes so she listens to the show too
and we know that we endorse it I
literally met Julia Porter for five
minutes like we were like I met one of
her friends the last time I was in Miami
he's cool dude and we laugh and like we
went from one party to the next I just
like joined them and went to the next
party literally like hung out for five
minutes outside the party and then we
went to live and live was so crazy that
like I couldn't even be closer I was
like in the middle everywhere doing my
own thing yeah so but apparently we're
dating yeah you kind of ship it but
she's a cool girl she was cool from the
five minutes I got to know her do you
find that frustrating like I'm sure you
know the tabloids gonna be running amuck
that the three of us are now in a
throuple which would it be the worst I'm
just terrible ever but do you find it
frustrating do you feel like when you're
out in public you have to act a certain
way I kinda got over that I just
do me and have one because if you always
just you know cater to the public you're
gonna you're gonna be miserable yeah I
mean but I've learned the kind of ways
that navigate in and have my phone in my
way and you know I mean but it's just
like I hate it you know anyone I stand
next to is my new girlfriend right and
it's not like that at all
she could be my girlfriend yeah I think
but uh but no I mean it's just like like
the person I want to date you know just
like you know I wouldn't want to date
somebody it's gonna create so much
pressure on that person and it's you got
to have the right person who go through
that right in a lot of ways it's a lot
easier for you to date now but also a
lot harder yeah yeah well you've been
linked to a lot of different people and
I just have one question
have you met stormy Webster a little bit
about ABC food tour is what it is yeah I
would love to I'm very passionate by ABC
Food Tours is literally one of my
favorite things we got to have you guys
come join us what is it
ABC Food Tours basically what we do is
we take our kids on like these fitness
and food excursions we work with all
title one schools all like the other
privileged schools and all of our kids
you know we take them out the principal
picks out what class we get to work with
and we take him on like like our last
class for instance we went to overthrow
which is a boxing gym and our kids were
working I mean I had this one kid I was
so proud of him we had like 30 seconds
about downs peas the worst it would
represent the worst workout there is but
I had this kid going for it and he was
in like a fool gray sweat suit and he
was porn swag but like like he pushed
himself way further than he's ever been
pushed before and I just see his relief
and then like I gave him the biggest hug
afterwards and like I don't know it was
incredible and then after that we we
kind of mob around the whole city I have
a sneaker and I'm playing tic TOCs on
we're hitting the renegade dancing all
these things look at you yesterday
really
very high because the kids are great
coaches but you know in order to be like
cool with the kids you throw it up and
then you catch it that's it that's it
yeah so then I'm like we then went to I
think it's called chefs corner which is
like a nice restaurant in the Soho area
and our kids got to so what they do is
they have like a new chef coming every
month
oh [ __ ] Club yeah chef oh I just ate
there actually it's really good and so
the last chef was from North Carolina
and she studied culinary in Spain so all
of her you know all the subject riser
cookies all you know Spain related
Spanish and she came in and she had John
bone and she was cutting it off you know
the hand leg for all these kids and and
they were loving it and it's like things
they've never experienced I mean I never
experienced that's the first time I ever
had someone cut something off the leg
and give it to me so I mean I'm learning
as I go too right well I mean what's
incredible as we learned so much from
these kids there was one day we were
sitting here with one of our kids and at
the end of the tour he has like his
pockets are all full and we bring we
call him over here like what's in your
pockets and he has all the food from the
whole tour in his pockets he said well
my mom loves chicken sandwiches and we
really like that and like he saved all
the food so his family could eat it it's
just like how selfless they are right
you know it's just incredible and this
just all smiles and fun and you know we
really love what we're doing we just
started a cool program with uh we did
with does Toros mm-hmm and we wanted to
kind of try and grow this program where
during the wintertime and dare
anything's giving there's when the kids
aren't in school there's a food desert
that's created because there's no you
know they don't have those breakfast and
lunch you know all the time and so we
did we give our kids a band and this
band allowed them to go into those Toros
during certain hours of the day and get
reduced-price meals played throughout
the day yeah so some we want to grow and
keep like you know this before you are
the bachelor after before but I'm sure
now after like that's a great platform
yeah yeah no yeah exactly and it's well
I mean we started before and like and
then like I want on the show
I cannot the show and all the ABC people
were giving me a big stink about it
because ABC food tours and I'm like no
guys this is way before I was like
Bachelor guided tours but we started an
alphabet city so it's really really
sweet do you just you ever open your DMS
sometimes I'm sure you get some wild D
and some crazy things in there actually
just the most I'll let you go through it
oh my god I just want to see like
titties like I think it would be amazing
no you're the most eligible bachelor in
America right now yeah how does it feel
good mom it's not really my focus I got
a lot of cool things I'm working on and
that's kind of my focus already show
with kwibi right Avenue so equipping
which is dogs with dogs
yes I do have a dog I rescued a pot cake
from the Bahamas of course you did so it
was she's my little girl
but she's with my mom now my mom's a
empty nester and you're seen these are
so your mom and your family's in Florida
right yeah yeah we go back to Florida is
everyone just like shook at like what
happened to you because a lot of people
go on The Bachelor but they don't end up
like being cared about as much as people
seem to be really obsessed with you so
when you go home where people just
confuse cuz you left and you really
never getting back no yeah I mean it's
my go home it's fun I get with all my
old friends and we all go on the boat do
all the same stuff that we always did
and it's a great time you know I kind of
stay away from some of the bars now
right because they can get a little
crazy I wonder like when I go I want to
be my friends right you know yeah I'll
hang out with people and like you know
take pictures and say hi and meet new
people which I love doing but I you know
there's times where I just want to be
with my friends and hang out and but
it's uh going home was fun I'm going
home at the end of the month and for a
week and I'm actually gonna I might try
to stop in Tallahassee to see my brother
see Juliette yeah she does look if you
wanted to do I'm gonna try and stop in
Tallahassee in Gainesville with my
brothers they're all gonna come
and one of my favorite a kid I really
really like is that up and coming
rappers on tour gonna stop through there
so I want to go hang out it's my
brother's last semester at FSU before he
goes into the military
speaking of tick tock you brothers all
over taken is that the one that's the
youngest one he's a freshman okay yeah
he's funny he's killing it sometimes I
see you I'm like oh that guy looks like
Tyler and then Tyler comes in the
tic-tock he's always on my page ya know
he's he's great yes and that's my guy
he's so creative keep doing work you're
doing well would you ever recommend that
one of them go on The Bachelor yeah I
think Ryan would be great for it Austin
would he's more quiet and more
introverted you'd have to definitely
push himself to open up more but he's
fantastic kid lovely to the death I
think any girl that he is with is very
lucky to be with him so he would someone
you'd be great for the show a little
sister how did you get on The Bachelor
what was your audition process oh that
so that was a it was kind of funny you
know I was um so I was a basically just
a broke jock I was trying to you know
play football and go pro and got hurt
and didn't work out and had like three
classes left for my MBA so I was home I
moved back home and was at my mom's
house and one day I was taking a break
from studying I saw like the ad for it
and I kind of like you know typed in
some funny things and and then saw like
a you know you have to send in a picture
I send in like the just like the most
douchiest photos like there's some ice
creams like me on the beach like this
during one of my it was during one of my
um like football practices and we had a
cameraman and I was like in the injury
group so I was just like rolling around
the water at school and that picture was
captured so I saw like screenshot it
sends to the boys like dude send it in
they see what happens you know sent it
in and what's it called and then like
the producers hit me up a week later and
they're like you send photos and videos
yeah yeah I'll do it I'll do it just
never really got to it and then they
like we need you something photos or
videos like another week goes by and
never really got to and then like can we
just guy I was like alright let's Skype
Skype
and I don't even know if my skype was
working because I couldn't even see
myself my camera my computer isn't work
because the same computer hats it's like
freshman year college so I had use my
phone and like they like you're telling
me how to use lights and all this stuff
yeah the camera wouldn't let me see
myself so I'm like I don't know if she's
looking at my nose if I got boogers you
know and but I guess she likes me and I
just kind of snowball from there that's
so crazy it's just it's just so crazy
because it's when did your journey on
The Bachelor start airing like only like
a year ago right yeah I remember I
remember the day our call was February
14th which was Valentine's Day the day I
went on the show was marked or like left
for the show was March 14th as and the
day I got back was May 14th it was like
weird all on the 14th
I'm still under contract with ABC yeah
okay so the next question you probably
can't answer but I just have so many
questions about that weird paparazzi
photo of human Hannah the day after she
pretended that like she wasn't upset
like that she still liked you and then
all of a sudden like you leaving her
apartment in the morning like she's
wearing your boxers I just was like
everything about backpack I was like
totally staged and I know you can't
probably tell me but just like blink
twice if it was staged I did leave her
place but just as friends I don't I mean
someone's calling somebody to let us
know that they're right right right yeah
and it was very it was organized yeah
well so there's a lot there's a big
question of whether or not Hannah and
Peter are gonna end up together because
she tried yet it didn't work out she
tried you don't work out and now I guess
Peters next I guess I don't know Chris
Harrison is after that so but she's
someone I also feel bad for because
everyone she stands next to is the her
new boyfriend yeah yeah and it puts a
lot of pressure on her you know and I
think um I think it's a difficult thing
to go through and so I don't know if
it's her and Peter I don't know who it
is but I do think her and Peter are much
I think so I think you know we saw how
happy they were to see each other and
all that and they had incredible
chemistry when we were on the show
together they had a little secret
chemistry because they we'd like Peter
we also said we all you know
my chemistry Peter was like a dark horse
it came out of nowhere right but then
when I saw it play back on the show my
Peter you dog on the pool table
we never saw heard about it right right
when you were in it and a lot of people
like talked about in hindsight like they
knew who was gonna win like did you guys
know it was gonna be Jed did you think
gonna be you know so so Jed definitely
like hit it off with her right away and
that was a relationship that kind of
started early and was strong yeah weird
and with me first of all I was like
shell-shocked
I was scared to talk to anybody the
house like the first week and a half I
was like intimidated I was like freaking
out and then and then so but they had
their whole relationship going on like
kind of from the get-go you know I
didn't even talked with the first night
and then I key like kind of always you
know really you know kind of kept me at
bay and they never really kind of like
it took time for us to break down walls
and stuff like that so I think that kind
of prolonged our relationship made it
like harder for us to build it right
away when it's a game of how quickly can
you build a relationship you know and so
it definitely like I came in late you
know our relationship really picked up a
lot towards the end and I really thought
I was I was you know going to be her guy
and that we were going to make this work
and it was tough for sure yeah my
paradise it's really fun I've heard I
think the guys will be great on the next
season not you and you won't be one of
them I I mean you can never say never
anything you know but I just have so
many things I want to do right will work
I wouldn't say it's not real work that's
you know it's hard work actually it's
yes right I heard I read a little bit of
the article with Blake that came out how
like it's just hot and yeah there's no
like first of all there's no a/c mm-hmm
which means I would never sleep there's
bugs and you're allowed to wear
sunglasses because nobody ever is
wearing something yeah you defecate wear
sunglasses yeah
but um yeah I just sounds like my worst
nightmare like if I don't have if my
room's not 69 degrees 67 degrees
[Laughter]
my room has to be an ice chamber and if
it's not I'm you know and then I can't I
won't even like myself so how could I
like somebody else I just be groggy and
miserable totally yeah it doesn't seem
like the ideal place to fall in love no
but I would never send ever though I
think it's uh it's fun the guys you know
like Dylan Hanna right it was a
fantastic experience for them you know
they went through some hardships but
they grew from it and they are the
happiest couple I've seen in a long time
they're disgusting I think I really have
to try and get in between them okay and
I break them apart I mean like when we
were and we went to rolling loud
together and eásá the video that the
Barstow people put up so we did I was
there with like Aria and Fran from the
chasing office and and all them and they
were they were doing a little vlog for
the weekend and you know me and Hannah
got separated Dylan lost it was
hilarious but no I mean they they are I
think a great success story from the
show I think but they're just incredibly
happy they're living the maldis living
it up right now and yeah I think they're
both incredible people and I think they
were supposed to find each other
on paradise so I think you know there is
positive in it and that's why I'll never
say never yeah yeah nice I think I would
like to see you on there I mean we would
love it yeah yeah what about stagecoach
paradise good question our days prequel
making yeah for real I guess if you need
to find love you get a stagecoach I
don't know I'm so out of tune with
country music right now like I love the
older country music right well actually
the lineup does really highlight Alan
Jackson is very old-school and I like
like I don't know Rascal Flatts no oh
wow I was like East Easton Corbin is my
favorite country artist interesting what
about chase rice chase rice is good yeah
there was drama got caught up in a love
triangle yeah yeah but uh I even like it
was a huge fan of Jake on before the
show so that was so cool to have him
perform
yeah
because like I grew up in Jupiter
Florida grew up of your Beach where my
grandparents live which is 35 minutes 40
minutes north of where I live so like I
just loved his music and like that was a
really cool experience yes but no I love
country music but I'm just like I'm so
out of tune with what it is now did you
listen to his song Alabama Hannah
it's about Hannah obviously is he going
for Hannah I don't know it was a weird
thing that he did yeah
and we're like is this about Hannah and
he was like yeah I mean it's gonna get
like he's gonna get saw listens like a
marketing genius yeah that's so fun I'm
switching gears you struck up a
friendship with Andy Cohen who will last
night of course he does where where to
see what the Tom Snyder's show and like
this like we said like I was there I got
there early and then all of a sudden and
he walks in and they're like oh this is
a nice eat oh you got to be kidding me
how do you know him well I did his show
watch what happens live oh yeah then we
kind of stayed in touch and I always
loved commenting on his stuff you love
you know we comment on my stuff and we
always like are like messaging back and
forth we're gonna stay you know about
working out or like we always just miss
each other like we just was each other
in Miami right I just missed him we were
it was Miami I think another time that
just missed him as well but a huge fan
of Andy he's hilarious he's someone who
I want to kind of hang around his show
and I told him like that says I don't
wanna hang around a show watch and
listen to you and he's incredible what
did you think of being on watch happens
live did you have a good time it was a
blast yeah it was a blast I've got to
kind of witness some of that the Real
Housewives drama
hmm which is absolutely crazy you Bart
ended I bartend you know who are the
guests were you ever um do you like
another reality show like a Bravo show
maybe if you're in New York a summer
house if you lived in LA don't do summer
house like you know we should be down I
know you're with ABC right now but I
just I don't I don't watch TV really so
I don't even know what shows there are
what they are so like that's why the
house I don't I don't know you wouldn't
know yeah do you we're having a TV in
your apartment I just got one do you've
cable no what are you yeah who got it
okay you can watch The Bachelor now live
yeah that's why you got it it's live I
think so yeah yeah yeah so we got all
the sports because of Hulu right next
step is uh to get a TV in my room yeah
GameChanger
yeah I love having a TV in my room I had
same okay so I feel like that's all the
questions I had for you is there
anything else Jackie before we let him
go
no just thank you for coming on yeah and
you know what I really was championing
you dating Stas like if that works out
just know you have our blessing yeah I
appreciate everyone can follow Tyler on
Instagram at Tyler Jay Cameron 3 3 3 for
updates on the food tour you know his
new creepy show and just general
shirtless pics so thank you so much for
being here thank you for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up
we're also the elbows a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found set Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I hurt me to
cashbox
so ever you listen to podcasts high
that's fine how are ya leave a review 5
stars maybe a comment about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are up
to you just some creative you know
guidance have a great day we'll see you
tomorrow last show of the week